it's andy burnham thanks ever so much
for uh taking the time this morning
i think i'm right in saying you
acknowledge the necessity
of these measures but you think the
manner in which they were announced was
a little bit clumsy
that's a pretty good summary um but yes
on the substance we
we do uh accept that uh these steps are
needed
they're modest steps um you know we're
asking people
uh not to have visitors at home um
if they go to the pub to stick within
their own household
steps that hopefully will prevent
much more severe restrictions if we we
take firm action at this time and the
reason for it colin is
the picture changed in greater
manchester over the last week we're
watching the data very very closely like
the government is
so when the government contacted me to
say look we think something is happening
here
i could already see that it was and it
wasn't just in one locality
there was a change across all of our
boroughs and that's why we said to the
government that they were
they were right to take quick action
yeah we'll come into the measures
uh specifically in a moment but just in
terms of how you make these
announcements
it's quite difficult for the government
isn't it really because i know they were
criticized for instance with the
quarantine period in the fact they
announced that on a saturday evening
people had five hours notice but there
was a reason for that as well to stop
people sort of circumventing the rules
flying back early
there isn't there isn't a perfect way of
making these announcements or is there
no i don't think there is a perfect way
and i understand how hard this is
for government ministers having been one
uh myself
and i think at the moment they're
adopting a
feels like a new strategy of the minute
they see something they are taking
decisive action and i think that's
probably the right way to go but here's
the one
caveat i would place on it they they
have a habit of saying something and
then it being a few hours until the
detail emerges and that certainly was
the case
last night and you know later on last
night a lot of people i think felt very
uncertain
as to what exactly was being announced
so
what i would say to them is i understand
the need to make announcements i
understand the need for decisive action
but when ministers go in front of the
cameras make sure you've got the detail
ready to go exactly at the same time
yeah
i i'm sure they might say it's it's
difficult when you've got lots of
stakeholders involved and
if somebody knows something then they
might put it tweet it and suddenly the
message is out and it can look quite
ham-fisted can't it just in terms of the
enforceability of the thing
um to some degree this is going to be
devolved to local authorities
obviously uh local police forces as well
how enforceable do you think this is
this is going to prove clearly it's
going to be challenging
we're going to have to look to to people
themselves first to do the right thing
and to respect these new requirements
because they're being brought in for a
good reason that is to protect everybody
uh here let's get to the substance of it
as well though i think the reason the
government have chosen these particular
measures
is because of the evidence of a rising
cases in
households where there were gatherings
and i think that's why they wanted a
very clear statement on that particular
issue and this doesn't just relate to um
multi-generational households look where
people are living together
we've seen uh situations in parts of
greater monster where there's been a
rising cases amongst uh younger people
and that it's felt possibly is also
linked to
uh to house gatherings so i can
understand why the government is sending
a really clear message uh
on that particular issue uh and i would
say to everybody
the quicker we follow this advice
the quicker these restrictions will be
lifted i've agreed with the secretary of
state that they will be reviewed weekly
uh so you know this is a a preventative
step if you like
on the precautionary principle and i
think if we all
follow it it's not a massive change to
make and it's not a huge amount to ask
then i think we could um we could
quickly see these cases come back down
in the other direction
yeah as you say it's different
communities that are affected there's
a particular focus hasn't there on as
you say uh
homes multiple occupancy
intergenerational uh
habitation going on there um we've got
eid coming up this weekend
what is your message to people of south
asian ancestry
in in the two amongst the 2.8 million
mancunians you represent
uh as they approach this weekend it's
it's a difficult balancing act between
wanting to observe religious ceremonies
and rituals and
and pay homage to all that whilst
observing these new social distancing
rules
well certainly you know i recognize how
um disruptive this might be to people's
uh plans as you say with with the
uh this weekend uh people can still uh
go uh
to the mosque so there's no uh
restriction on on that
of course people would have to observe
distancing uh in the mosque but
there's been a lot of work going on to
ensure that the proper measures are in
place there
so it's not about preventing people
going to worship it is of course about
gatherings back at home uh and that
is something that nobody has kind of
wanted to have to do but
uh the circumstances have pretty much
demanded it
and it's true of everybody really it's
decent weather today here in greater
manchester we're
not always in a position to say that but
we are today and you know
we've got to say to everybody in all
parts of the the city region
you know plea well you can't don't
gather in your home um
because this is clearly a source of
spread of the virus
amongst all age groups actually and in
all geographies
and that's why the government
reluctantly i
accepted that they were they were right
to propose this measure
and i suppose that the blunt truth is if
this doesn't work you can expect
more draconian lockdown measures well we
don't want to see that and i've been
arguing
uh against that in many ways you know
that we need all of the data to stop
that happening so you will have heard me
on
your your programs over recent weeks
saying give us the data
let us see the picture and finally that
data came through
once the government kind of agreed to
what i was saying so i i could see
exactly what they could see
earlier this week and so could all of
the council leaders in greater
manchester
and we could see that there was a
problem that required firmer action
so when the health secretary called me i
wasn't surprised you know i kind of
was in the same mindset myself you know
what are we going to do here to quickly
nip this situation
in the bud so you know having called for
the data having had the ability to see
the picture
uh obviously i was in a position to
agree with what with what he was
with what he was saying uh andy burnham
very good to talk to you thank you
thanks very much